right now we've got another ng exclusive
for you only we were on the set of isn't
it romantic with rebel Wilson and Liam
Hemsworth we'll just needs more and more
romantic comedy I think it's always a
good thing to go with your partner to
see a film is he romantic felt let's
just say Miley is a very lucky lady as
Liam Hemsworth shares his shirtless
glory for the world in the new comedy
isn't it romantic good morning beautiful
last night was amazing I think we
actually did anything and just cut to
the next morning what just get back here
okay rebel Wilson produced the film she
plays Natalie a lifelong cynic when it
comes to love but probably an accident
she wakes up to discover she's the star
of her very own
cheesy rom-com Liam is her over the top
leading man are you feeling what I'm
feeling
no Liam I have a bit of sexiness going
on in this movie we've already kissed in
the right and already in this amazing
dress that's kind of like what Julia
Roberts wears in Pretty Woman and that
cost six thousand dollars to build that
the dip and gift she trips over and I
catch her ever so romantic Leigh and
Liam charms weren't lost on co-star
Priyanka Chopra a super chill guy you
know funny really stays you know humble
what is the most romantic thing you've
ever done
you know it's just the usual stuff
showering her in rose petals full-body
massages just the usual stuff really
[Music]